krachende niederlage für premier boris
johnson die zwangspause für das
britische parlament domino effekt bringt
die thomascook pleite die
tourismusbranche ins trudeln welt
fußball gala in mailand jürgen klopp und
michael rapino freuen sich übertroffen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen an diesem dienstag
kristin otto ist auch dabei für den
sport ja hallo und guten abend
herber hätte das urteil für boris
johnson kaum ausfallen können einstimmig
entschied das oberste gericht
großbritanniens der premierminister hat
gegen die verfassung verstoßen die von
ihm angeordnete fünfwöchige zwangspause
für das parlament ist null und nichtig
einen grund zurückzutreten sie johnson
trotzdem nicht aus london andreas stamm
draußen regnerisch ein wenig trostlos
wie auch der sitzungssaal doch umso
aufsehenerregender das urteil
die suspendierung des parlaments so das
oberste gericht null und nichtig das
urteil ein stille die entscheidung der
königin zu empfehlen das parlament zu
suspendieren war gesetzeswidrig sei sie
gedacht war das parlament davon
abzuhalten seine verfassungsmäßigen
rechte auszuüben ohne eine stichhaltige
begründung der exit vollziehen ohne dass
das parlament eine entscheidende stimme
hat sei gegen die grundprinzipien der
demokratie die opposition überrascht die
eindeutigkeit des urteils ganz klar und
sehr hart und kritisch gegenüber boris
johnson hat nicht nur der königin
belogen sondern auch hat auch das gesetz
verbrochen und er muss ein bus
zurücktreten das link johnson gerade in
new york bei der uno umgehend ab er
fordert neuwahlen wird am abend früher
als geplant zurückreisen
ich bin überhaupt nicht mit diesem
urteil einverstanden
wir werden uns dennoch nicht dabei
beirren lassen den willen des volkes
umzusetzen und am 31 oktober die eu
verlassen
morgen tritt das parlament wieder
zusammen erklärt der unterhaus sprecher
umgehend ein sieg der abgeordneten den
machtkampf mit der regierung der 1 zeigt
ob parlament suspendieren oder gesetze
missachten mit juristisch
fadenscheinigen manövern führt für boris
johnson wohl kein weg zum break sind
diana zimmermann in london was heißt das
denn jetzt für den wechsel bei der
praxis geht davon nicht weg das
allerdings ein dreck so kommt wie gottes
chancen dass heute auch immer wieder
betont hat das wird zunehmend
unwahrscheinlich parlament und gericht
habe neben heute klar gemacht dass sie
nicht zulassen werden dass er den
wechsel zum 31 oktober einfach so durch
trägt er dagegen hat sehr klar gemacht
dass er versuchen wird jede politische
niederlage selbst eine so heftige wie
heute zu seinen politischen nutzen
umzudeuten
er hat gesagt dieses dieses urteil werde
er akzeptieren halte es aber für falsch
er hat klar gemacht dass er das für eine
art störfeuer von brt exit gegnern hält
während er heldenhaft weiter für einen
eu-austritt kämpft warum macht er das
neuwahlen werden kommen früher oder
später und boris johnson glaubt dass er
mit diesem selbst gestrickten heldenepos
hier im land eine mehrheit gewinnen kann
vielen dank nach london diana zimmermann
für den vw-konzern ist es ein desaster
fast vier jahre nachdem die us-behörden
den diesel skandal aufgedeckt haben
klagt die staatsanwaltschaft
braunschweig jetzt die
unternehmensspitze an wegen
marktmanipulation
das wäre beispiellos wenn das amtierende
führungsduo sowie der ehemalige
vorstandschef des weltgrößten
automobilkonzerns tatsächlich vor
gericht müssten
oliver deuker und elisabeth schmidt die
anschuldigungen der staatsanwaltschaft
braunschweig wiegen schwer zu spät
sollen die drei vw manager den
aktienmarkt über die finanziellen folgen
des dieses skandals informiert haben
anleger hätten dadurch viel geld
verloren
den angeschuldigten so erhobene vorwurf
sei aufgrund der sich aus der brisanz
der thematik ergebenden erheblichen
finanziellen folgen bewusst gewesen dass
diese dem kapitalmarkt mitzuteilen
gewesen wären
sie hätten jedoch jeder für sich bewusst
und gewollt von der erforderlichen
mitteilung
ad hoc abgesehen unverständnis bei
volkswagen das unternehmen habe den
sachverhalt auch von externen experten
untersuchen lassen
vor der zdf kamera wollte sich vw nicht
äußern dafür in einem firmenvideo
sollte es zu einem prozess kommen sind
wir überzeugt davon dass sämtliche
vorwürfe sich als haltlos erweisen
werden
auch die anwälte der beschuldigten
weisen die vorwürfe mit aller
entschiedenheit zurück
zitat herr doktor dies hat sich im
zusammenhang mit der diese problematik
nicht das geringste zu schulden kommen
lassen er wird weiterhin mit vollem
engagement seiner aufgaben im konzern
wahrnehmen
herbert diess im chefsessel und auch
vielleicht bald auf der anklagebank
nicht unproblematisch für den volkswagen
konzern die noch immer der abgas betrug
beschäftigt gleichzeitig aber richtung
e-mobilität umgebaut wird
ob die drei dann wirklich auf der
anklagebank sitzen werden die vorwürfe
der staatsanwaltschaft muss nun das
landgericht braunschweig prüfen und
entscheiden ob es tatsächlich zu einem
prozess kommt vw porsche und audi haben
schon milliarden an bußgeldern im diesel
skandal gezahlt jetzt ist auch daimler
dran mit 870 millionen euro
die staatsanwaltschaft stuttgart
verhängte die strafe wegen fahrlässiger
verletzung der aufsichtspflicht daimler
akzeptierte den bußgeldbescheid
unabhängig davon wird weiter wegen
betrugs gegen daimler verantwortliche
ermittelt
und jetzt nach new york zur
un-vollversammlung us-präsident begriff
bei der generaldebatte erneut iran an
und drohte damit die sanktionen zu
verschärfen
jum brief die anderen staaten zu einem
harten kurs auf keine
verantwortungsbewusste regierung dürfe
so wörtlich die blut lust irans
unterstützen job macht das land unter
anderem für angriffe auf ölanlagen in
saudi arabien verantwortlich nach der
rede traf jump die bundeskanzlerin um
sich mit ihr über den konflikt mit iran
auszutauschen und danach sprach angela
merkel dann auch mit dem iranischen
präsidenten roh hanni johannes hano in
new york was tut sich da gerade
also scheint sich tatsächlich etwas zu
bewegen das knie hat sich gestern abend
schon angedeutet die europäer haben in
einer gemeinsamen erklärung sich auf die
amerikaner zu bewegt um 22 zentralen
fragen zum einen hat man gesagt der iran
steht dahinter ist eine position die man
bisher nicht hatte und zum anderen hat
man den iran aufgefordert jetzt auch
über das raketenprogramm zu verhandeln
das war eine der zentralen forderungen
die donald trump immer wieder
aufgestellt hat gesagt das ganze
abkommen seien misst das schlechteste
abkommen aller zeiten weil eben nicht
über terrorismus und raketenprogramm
verhandelt wird also da ist man dem
amerikanischen präsidenten entgegen
gekommen
auf der anderen seite ist man aber auch
bleibt man bei der position dass die
iraner kommen insgesamt nichts sich
verändern dürfe und das hat die
kanzlerin jetzt wohl auch gerade mit
präsident trump besprochen in einem
spontanen gespräch und hat gesagt okay
wir europäer haben uns bewegt aber jetzt
ist die amerikaner euch auch bewegen und
jetzt hofft man dass es vielleicht doch
noch zu einem treffen zwischen cabrio
honeycomb
aber das wissen wir nicht gehen diese
aktuelle einschätzung johannes hano nach
deutschland große unsicherheit herrscht
bei condor kunden und condor
mitarbeitern nach der pleite des
mutterkonzerns thomas cook gestern
fliegt condor zwar noch braucht aber
jetzt geld und hofft auf einen
millionenkredit der bundesregierung
condor ist die drittgrößte deutsche
fluggesellschaft sie befördert jährlich
mehr als 7 millionen passagiere im
einsatz sind 58 flugzeuge und rund 4900
mitarbeiter ein profitables unternehmen
eigentlich stefan schlosser der
flugbetrieb läuft heute ganz normal wer
bei condor gebucht hat kann die geplant
in den urlaub starten
wir haben also nicht mit seiner
tochtergesellschaft dennoch ist bei
vielen reisenden die verunsicherung groß
was wird aus condor
ohne eine finanzspritze könnte es bald
eng werden
es hängt alles am seidenen faden im
moment die condor hat gerade mit thomas
cook den großen kunden verloren der nun
auch nicht mehr zahlt gleichzeitig
werden die konto lieferanten jetzt
vorkasse verlangen
also flughäfen flugbenzin muss alles
cash bezahlt werden das geht nicht lange
gut
auch air berlin hatte der staat seiner
zeit unter die arme gegriffen mit 150
millionen euro
das geld wurde komplett zurückgezahlt
geholfen hat es am ende zwar nicht aber
im gegensatz zu air berlin arbeitet
condor profitabel und macht gewinne ist
eine gute marke sehr gut verankert bei
fluggästen wertig hat tolle beschäftigte
der arbeiten rund 4900 menschen die
wirklich mit herz und seele im
unternehmen dabei sind und ich glaube
dass auch die eine chance verdient haben
kritik dagegen vom bund der steuerzahler
condor aber eben auch thomas cook sind
große unternehmen konzerne die
marktwirtschaftlich orientiert unterwegs
sind deswegen sollte sich der staat hier
auf gar keinen fall einmischen denn es
handelt sich hier um steuergeld die
bundesregierung prüft derzeit den antrag
und jetzt hat auch die deutsche thomas
cook einen überbrückungskredit beantragt
über die höhe ist aber noch nichts
bekannt es gibt viele leidtragende der
kug pleite die mitarbeiter natürlich
hundert tausende gestrandete urlauber
und eben auch hotels die sich fragen wer
die offenen rechnungen zahlt christoph
distel berichtet hurghada in ägypten
sonne das wasser 28 grad warm und nur
ein problem die die hier eigentlich
ausspannen wollen wissen genau mein
reiseveranstalter ist pleite sonst
müssen sie fast nichts wenn man
fernsehen guckt dann sind der gerüchte
von urlaubern die in ihren hotels
angeschlossen werden
dahinter steckt ein riesenproblem alle
pauschal kunden haben bezahlt aber nur
bei thomas cook wegen der pleite sehen
die hotels davon keinen cent arbeiten
seit etwa zwei monaten praktisch umsonst
sind selbst ratlos
flughafen regus spanien hotels die
urlauber unter druck setzen
solche gerüchte hat man auch hier gehört
sehr konkret sogar da waren zwei paare
bei uns in der anlage
die konnten plötzlich nicht mehr in ihre
zimmer ausgesperrt rein durften sie erst
wieder nachdem sie für die nächsten tage
340 euro bezahlt hatten
balearen kanaren und andalusien gerade
spanische hotels müssen sehen wo sie
bleiben von offenen rechnungen über 200
millionen euro ist die rede
dann griechenland allen voran rhodos kos
kreta
dort sollen bis zu 500 millionen euro
fehlen und so müssen sich auch in
iraklion die hotels entscheiden auf
staatshilfen hoffen oder vorsichtshalber
die eigenen gäste schon mal gängeln und
was ist mit herbst und winter das ist
ein extrem schweres erdbeben und wir
warten jetzt auf den tsunami und sie
wissen ja die größte zerstörung bringt
meister zunahmen
einer geht pleite eine halbe branche
könnte er damit ins wanken bringen
abgeschottete subkulturen mit einer
eigenen werteordnung sowie definiert
bka-präsident münch kriminelle
familienclans in deutschland erstmals
legte er bundesweite zahlen vor am
aktivsten sind die clowns demnach in
nordrhein westfalen bundesweit gibt es
rund 650 tatverdächtig
die größte gruppe sind die libanesen
großer wahltag heute bei den fraktionen
im bundestag die spd abgeordneten
bestimmten rolf mützenich ihren
kommissarischen vorsitzenden zum
regulären und das mit fast 98 prozent
die abgeordneten von fdp und afd
bestätigten ihre fraktionschefs
gegenkandidaten gab es nur bei den
grünen david gebhard berichtet
ein hauch von rebellion lag in der luft
vor der entscheidenden fraktionssitzung
bei den grünen gegenkandidatur vom ex
parteichef der sich optimistisch zeigt
alles wird gut
oder schau macht doch der versuch im duo
mit der abgeordneten kirsten kappa
gonther den fraktionsvorsitz zu erobern
scheitert bestätigt stattdessen das duo
göring eckardt hofreiter die die grünen
fraktion seit 2013 zusammenführen
ich freue mich sehr über das ergebnis
das ist ein deutliches signal dafür dass
wir den kurs der geschlossenheit
fortsetzen göring eckardt setzte sich
gegen ihre herausforderin mit rund 61
prozent durch kappa gonther war bisher
bundespolitisch kaum bekannt ich werde
mich jetzt wieder mit herzblut meinen
zentralen themen nämlich der
gesundheitspolitik und der kulturpolitik
zu wenden
in der zweiten abstimmung beste mir
gegen hofreiter setzte sich der bayer
mit gut 58 prozent durch ich bedanke
mich bei jam und kirsten für die faire
und allerdings auch spannende
auseinandersetzung ansonsten gilt die
alte weisheit wer kämpft kann verlieren
wer nicht kämpft hat schon verloren
fürsten ihr bedeutet das ergebnis
weiterhin ein platz in der zweiten reihe
und für die neuen alten fraktionschefs
den auftrag sich stärker zu profilieren
auch gegenüber der eigenen parteiführung
18 jahre lang stand er an der spitze der
dienstleistungsgewerkschaft verdi
heute hat frank bsirske den staffelstab
an frank werneke übergeben
ein grünen-mitglied als
gewerkschaftsboss 2001 passte das vielen
mitgliedern erstmal nicht es folgen
hunderte tarifverhandlungen vor allem
nachts 2015 ist eines seiner hauptziele
erreicht der gesetzliche mindestlohn den
empfindlichen mitgliederschwund konnte
bsirske aber nicht aufhalten
michael währung über den alten und den
neuen vorsitzenden
gewählt mit 92,7 prozent das ist nicht
nur ein starker vertrauensbeweis für
frank werneke
das ist auch ein vertrauensvorschuss mit
dem 52 jahre alten gelernten
verpackungsmittelmechaniker endet nach
18 jahren die ära frank bsirske an der
spitze von verdi fast genauso lang war
während sein stellvertreter zuständig
für finanzen im vergleich zu ski bar
wernecke bisher ein mann der leisen
worte was nicht heißt dass er keine
klaren standpunkt hätte ich bin
gewerkschaft haben weil ich unrecht
überwinden will
weil ich nicht akzeptiere dass jeder und
jede fünfte beschäftigte in deutschland
zu bedingungen des niedriglohn arbeiten
muss das mini jobs weiter grassieren und
altersarmut dadurch anwächst
die fußstapfen seines vorgängers sind
groß suske hat verdi als dienstleistungs
gewerkschaft für an die 1000 berufe
aufgebaut und lohnsteigerungen hart
verhandelt notfalls mit streik auf der
anderen seite musste er
mitgliederschwund und eine erosion der
tarifbindung hinnehmen sein rat an den
nachfolger neugierig zu sein und zu
bleiben
die nähe zu den menschen zu suchen und
zu hören zu können nur zu hören zu
wollen
die erwartungen an den neuen sind
jedenfalls groß und führungsstärke
kampfbereitschaft und das verständnis
dass wir uns noch internationaler
aufstellen müssen sein geschick muss
wernicke bald beweisen schon im oktober
beginnen die vorbereitungen für die
tarifverhandlungen im öffentlichen
dienst und wir sind bei einem
strahlenden group christiane aber auch
wirklich richtig gut auch das erste
champions league gewinner und nun auch
welt fußball trainer des jahres jürgen
klopp ist ganz oben angekommen wird
überhäuft mit respekt und einzigartigen
komplimenten
er ist das gesicht des klubs des fc
liverpool
seine karriere ist um eine facette
schillernder geworden fällt trainer des
jahres erst der dritte deutsche nach
jupp heynckes und joachim löw der coach
des champions league siegers fc
liverpool gibt den bescheidenen
teamplayer
ich muss meiner mannschaft danken denn
als trainer bist du nur so gut wie sein
team die qualität der spieler ist das
eine was sie daraus machen das andere
ich bin unheimlich stolz auf die jungs
seit der den henkelpott nach liverpool
holte hat der einstige zweitliga spieler
nicht nur an der anfield road kultstatus
erreicht das war echt nicht zu erwarten
weder als die schule verlassen hat noch
noch als ich schon gemeldet habe dass so
etwas passieren würde ich habe jetzt
trotzdem ein spezieller moment
ein selbsternannter normal wenn der
normale nun also doch ein ganz
spezieller trainer jürgen klopp und eine
ausführliche dokumentation über und mit
jürgen klopp können sie in der zdf
mediathek sie bereits zum sechsten mal
so oft wie keiner zuvor wurde der
argentinier lionel messi vom fc
barcelona zum weltfußballer des jahres
gewählt und bei den frauen äußerte sich
us weltmeisterin miki kino nach ihrer
auszeichnung zur weltfußballerin sehr
bemerkenswert rihawi nie haben die große
chance im fußball anders als in anderen
sportarten unser spiel zu nutzen
die welt unter widrigen bedingungen
leeds in der britischen grafschaft
yorkshire das einzelzeitfahren der
frauen bei der straßenrad wm den titel
sicherte sich chloe geld aus den usa vor
der niederländerin anna van der becken
beste deutsche lisa klein auf rang fünf
lisa brennauer wurde zehnte und morgen
sind dann die männer dran
wir schauen aufs wetter der herbst
schlägt zu mit wind und schauen die
details hat gleich gunther tiersch claus
kleber begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn
im heute-journal danke für ihr interesse
haben sie noch einen schönen abend und
bis morgen wenn sie münden auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer windiges
schauerwetter lässt uns morgen den
herbst spüren etwas anders als dieses
ruhige neblige wetter heute morgen im
westen jetzt hat uns ein regengebiet
erreicht und das zieht dieses regenband
weiter nach osten überquert uns und was
folgt ist auch nur nasses wetter morgen
windiges wetter immer wieder schauer die
über uns hinweg ziehen teilweise auch
gewitter aber es kann auch mal
zwischendurch eine kleine regenpause
gehen ja heute nacht also der regen von
westen der die mitte deutschlands
erreicht und dann schau morgen früh auch
die oder es wird nicht so sehr kalt 10
bis 14 grad sind es und morgen früh wird
dann auch hier im westen der wind
stärker weht kräftig aus südwesten das
ist auch tagsüber der fall
wir haben weiterhin diesen starkem
südwestwind weitere schauer folgen immer
wieder wird es zwischendurch nass aber
es kann auch mal die sonne raus kommen
wir im nordwesten oder vielleicht auch
mal im süden wo der regel nicht ganz so
stark ist vereinzelt gibt es eben auch
gewitter und die temperaturen immer noch
nach im angenehmen bereich meist
zwischen 15 und 20 grad wechselhaft
geht's weiter in den nächsten tagen aber
wenigstens am freitag und samstag wird
es im süden sonnig und am freitag auch
22 grad war ich würde dir noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie's gut